ces civils qui continue de fuir on va
sur évidemment en fil rouge toute la
journée ces évacuations marina retour au
terrain où différents fronts ce côté
très près le premier c'est évidemment
qui est la capitale compenser imprenable
il ya encore quelques jours où est-ce
qu'on en est aujourd'hui et bien l'étau
se resserre sur la capitale et les
choses durent évidemment bien plus que
ce que moscou avait anticipé les troupes
sont toujours bloqués cette fameuse
colonne au nord et les forces russes se
concentrent maintenant dans les
banlieues est nord ouest et ouest de
kiev on l'a vu hier il devrait y avoir
on anticipe un assaut d'ici deux à
quatre jours ces banlieues les voilà
donc vous avez irp in buschhaus tome
elle est à noter que le maire d'auch ce
tome elle est décédée en distribuant des
vivres hier en tout cas les forces
russes se prépare un à de nouvelles
opérations autour de kiev dans la zone
dire pin à l'ouest et à un petit peu
plus à l'ouest ici dans la zone de gros
varie ordre et les russes sont en train
d'être ravitaillées peut-être maintenant
du front sud alors on le sait au dessin
est encore pour le moment épargné même
si le président volodymyr zelensky
annoncé il ya encore quelques heures des
bombardements imminents oui le front sud
c'est là où les troupes russes avancent
le plus rapidement on va regarder
ensemble cette carte parce que c'est
intéressant l'assaut russe se poursuit
mais l'armée russe tâtonne quelque peu
en tout cas autour de la ville de
nicolaï et vous voyez qui a été qui a
été reprise par les ukrainiens c'est une
ville de 500000 habitants et vous le
voyez on le répète jamais assez l est
sur la route d'odessa qui est évidemment
une des principales cibles des forces
russes mikko live c'est sur leur chemin
et donc voilà ce que les russes veulent
faire ici leur zone de contrôle et bien
les russes veulent tout simplement
contourné cette ville en passant par le
fleuve bourg qui se trouvent ici
évidemment pour prendre odessa l'on peut
voir sur les réseaux sociaux les
habitants d'odessa se réveille tous les
matins avec cette angoisse de cette
attaque que l'on dit imminente
évidemment à la fois par la terre et par
les maires une attaque amphibie qui
devrait avoir lieu dans quelques heures
merci beaucoup marina pour ces
précisions à ces précieuses